ici à ramallah beaucoup de gens si ce
n'est dire tout le monde a regardé
l'annnonce de donald trump et de
benyamin nétanyahou pour ce qui est
présenté par le président américain
comme un plan de paix ambitieux mais ici
vous l'imaginez les réactions sont vives
et l'opposition est totale c'est mauvais
pour tous les palestiniens tous les
arabes dont les mondes à tout le monde
arabe et quid sorel sourire l'ouest
comme ici en cisjordanie beaucoup de
jours suivant la guerre va éclater jours
vous savez ce truc du cercle n'est pas
bon pour le peuple palestinien
ceci est notre terre et je la prends
dans le futur au moment où donald trump
recevait à washington benyamin
nétanyahou pour l' annonce de son plan
de paix pour le proche-orient une
réunion se tenait en territoire
palestinien autour du président de
l'autorité palestinienne mahmoud abbas
qu'on voit sur cette photo
autour de la table des représentants du
hamas et du fatah de mouvements qui ne
sont pourtant pas du tout sur la même
ligne politique une réunion donc quasi
historique ici en territoire palestinien
et qui fait donc la une des journaux ici
des phénix man and then you bottom
weight watchers est dans le nom de la
fille trop de pression mais très
bêtement le prochain vous voyez c'est
donc ainsi que je peux citer la pression
tous les gens nous attendent et maguette
biogen a qui ne sort pas des là où
quelqu'un d'autre ça ne fonctionnera pas
croyez moi ton qu'ils vivront pas
destiné au niveau à zoug racing et
ex-chef de quelques instants après
l'annnonce du fameux plan de paix par
donald trump des centaines de
palestiniens sont descendus dans les
rues brûlant des portraits à l'effigié
du locataire de la maison blanche
encore que laurent des drapeaux
israéliens ou américains ces
manifestations ont causé des blessures
d'au moins 13 personnes en cisjordanie
au lendemain de ces manifestations
la situation est calme ici à ramallah
mais la colère est intacte dans l'esprit
d'un certain nombre d'habitants et les
regards sont désormais tournés vers la
journée de vendredi qui sera un bon
indicateur du niveau de colère chez les
palestiniens le vendredi est une journée
traditionnellement marquée par de fortes
mobilisations
mais ici la colère a peut-être été
remplacée par une certaine forme de
lassitude
[Musique]